c'était cher bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
depuis ce matin voit que le port du
masque est obligatoire il est plutôt
bien respectée pour l'instant mais c'est
plus compliqué pour les distanciation
sociale ça va être difficile
selon vous de les respecter c'est moi
qui vous remercie
oui arrière est évidemment le port du
masque obligatoire est plutôt une très
très bonne chose
c'était attendu c'est une bonne chose
que ce soit ce soit mis en place
la différenciation sociale va évidemment
moi j'ai vu des images ce matin sur ce
fichier par l'excusé par un concurrent à
écouter sur la ligne 13 très compliqué
pourquoi parce que ça va monter en
charge dans les jours qui vont venir
aujourd'hui c'est le jour du
déconfinement donc les gens reprennent
le travail que doucement les entreprises
vont adapter leurs horaires
mais dans quelques jours je pense que
les transports vont vous montez en
charge va falloir transporter beaucoup
plus de monde et là ça va être beaucoup
plus compliqué donc je pense que ce qui
va être très compliqué ça va être
appliquée de faire appliquer les gestes
barrière dans la durée c'est surtout
dans la durée que ça va être très
compliqué aujourd'hui j'ai vu que
effectivement on a les plus respectés
joaillier aussi des l'image tout à
l'heure à 7 heures du matin en pointe
avec des distanciation social respectée
avec les sièges bareille qui était
également respecter mais j'espère en
tout cas que ce sera possible tout cas
la ratp met tout en place pour que ce
soit aussi 3000 salariés qui ont été
déployés dans les gares pour faire
appliquer les gestes barrière a surtout
la dispensation social c'est ça qui
reste le plus important
malgré tout je vous l'aurais peut-être
qu'il va être très compliqué c'est de
tenir dans la durée vous parlais
justement de ces trois messages en a qui
vont être déployés sur l'ensemble du
réseau transports parisiens le rôle
c'est de voir si les gestes barrières
sont appliquées ou pas leur nombre est
il sûr
pison selon vous alors suffisant
évidemment nous parce que je le répète
il va falloir tenir sur la durée et sur
toutes les horaires c'est une très bonne
chose qu'on ait pu déployer ses salariés
atp ap un million de salariés sous la
main pour pouvoir les déployer dans
toutes les stations et c'est pourquoi il
ya déjà un certain nombre de stations
qui sont restés fermés ce matin
moi je crois que je les dis déjà dans
des interviews précédentes je crois que
les pouvoirs publics doivent prendre
leurs responsabilités aussi en la
matière et c'est ça doit dépasser le
cadre des salariés de la ratp on doit
avoir des renforts pour les prochains
jours pour que ces deux-là cette
barrière puissent être respectés en
permanence et que toutes les stations
puisse ouvrir dans de bonnes conditions
encore une fois l'épisode de ce matin
sur la ligne 13 on a vu un métro bondé
ça ne pourra que se répéter si on n'a
pas le nombre de salariés nécessaires et
surtout encore une fois les salariés de
la ratp sont allés policiers donc leur
appliquer des gestes-barrières oui mais
dans une certaine mesure avec avec un
pouvoir relativement limité dans quel
état d'esprit
justement se trouvent aujourd'hui les
salariés de la ratp
cela inquiète et ont continué à assurer
je ne peux pas envie de le dire
puis le début de la crise les salaires
atp ou continuer à faire marcher les
transports en commun donc ils vont
continuer à le faire
l'état d'esprit simplement c'est une
certaine inquiétude évidemment mais
comme tous les français une certaine
inquiétude sur sur le déroulement du
duduk et confinement est ce que il ya
une possibilité de retour de l'épidémie
on voit dans certains pays ou en
allemagne par exemple en corée du sud il
ya des nouveaux foyers qui apparaissent
il ya cette inquiétude évidemment
néanmoins les salaires par tpg qu'il
veut son travail tout au service public
par tous qu'ils ne continuent à le faire
mais encore une fois si rien n'est fait
au niveau des pouvoirs publics pour
apporter une aide nécessaire
ça va être très compliqué de faire
appliquer cette barrière les trams ont
roulé le problème n'est pas là le
problème gilles à l'intérieur du train
hervé techart merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes aiguë du syndicat sud au
conseil d'administration de la ratp